il y a eu des débats de plus en plus
nombreux depuis le début de la crise du
covid-19 au sujet de la relocalisation
de la production de médicaments
alors
là c'est un point très important il
serait d'abord impossible et je souligne
le mot impossible de relaxer de
relocaliser l'ensemble de la chaîne de
production du médicament en France comme
d'ailleurs dans toute autre pays la
production des médicaments fait appel à
des nombreuses expertises et à de
nombreux acteurs qui ne trouvent pas
tous qui se trouve pas tous au même
endroit je vous donne un exemple et
c'est l'exemple du vaccin contre la
covid-19
ce vaccin est composé de 280 composants
et 9 étapes industrielles elles sont
toutes nécessaires à la fabrication de
ce vaccin alors il serait illusoire de
chercher à tous les à tous les localisés
en un seul pays mais j'irai même plus
loin ce n'est pas ce ne serait pas
souhaitable
notre conviction est que la meilleure
garantie en termes de sécurisation des
chaînes de production et de faire appel
au meilleur spécialistes dans chaque
domaine c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour ce vaccin et ses spécialistes sont
localisés dans de nombreux pays
et grâce à cette logique nous avons
réussi à faire preuve de flexibilité
nous avons pu soutenir
l'approvisionnement des patients
français en cœur et éviter toute rupture
concernant le vaccin contre la covid au
plus fort de la crise sanitaire
alors le plus important c'est
l'expertise selon nous et pas la
localisation
nous pensons donc qui serait intéressant
d'inciter les industriels à garantir la
robustesse et l'agilité de leur chaîne
de production plutôt que la
relocalisation en France de leur
production qui n'apportent pas de
garantie suffisante en termes
d'approvisionnement